[Musique]
vous savez cet achat par contre les
autres tu vois pas du tout qui sait
alors ok non france inter non non non
non ça fait jamais croisé manche un
petit peu largué jean pierre coffe tf1
jean pierre coffe vous êtes danseur à
l'opéra
samedi vaguement quelque chose bonsoir
en tout cas donc je connais dit moi je
vais arriver c'est qu'il s'est pas
dieudonné vous êtes bien bronzé vous
dites oui j'ai dit
voir les nos amis les arabes ouais j'ai
été à marrakech
oui j'ai fait un petit break dans mon
spectacle et ça va vraiment y lever du
soleil neigé pas ouais c'est à dire que
ce spectacle donc été prévu pour durer
et tester des bulles avril en avril et
ben apparemment puisque les gens
apparemment apprécié gens viennent les
gens viennent gens qui viennent puisque
les gens qui sont là comme ça qu'on va
manger comme ça ouais tous les soirs
jusqu'au 19 janvier des données en plus
ce spectacle
ces 100 francs pour les étudiants ah
ouais et la 360 franz en sortiront plus
de thunes j'ai béni 190 mois s'est mis
en scène par muriel robin c'est votre
amie muriel robin oui oui c'est ma quote
j'ai commencé ensemble avec roger louret
qui maintenant fait les années tubes
avec gérard louvin sur son dauphin roger
louret éclats la bande des années tubes
nous aimons beaucoup ici je dois dire et
alors vous étiez dans un spectacle ça
s'appelait les balades à de la jeune et
les baladins en agenais way un truc mais
j'essaie quand j'étais petit j'avais 19
ans ouais et alors le spectacle c'était
des folie amoureuse de rohm hier c'était
quoi le régnard bas c'est un auteur du
xviie siècle
sûrement un copain de molière c'est le
même style et moi je faisais un petit
valet et muriel robin c'est la jeune
première
je faisais la jeune vierge ouais moi
j'ai vu robin au zénith
la semaine dernière elle est
exceptionnelle son nouveau spectacle
faut le dire parce que vraiment si vous
avez l'occasion d'aller à voir un
spectacle c'est le meilleur one woman
show qu'elle ait fait je pense très
répandue les autres mais cela est
formidable parce que moi aussi j'ai une
oreillette
alors je suis en train de me pose moi
une question à temps ouais ouais non
mais si je m'entretiens les spectateurs
voilà j'ai ça dans le rail c'est bien
c'est bien que les gens ne sachent pas
ce matin donc oui d'accord je lui
demande combien il a vendu deux
cassettes dacquois la salle est vendu
combien de cassettes je pense qu'on
n'est pas loin des 300 milles au salut
augmenté de 10 tout est bon il s'en va
ça va tout va bien sûr ils sont contents
et là vous avez sorti un livre si on me
demande de vous de vous demander alors
si on me demande moi de ne pas vous
répondre je suis moi aussi je veux bien
lui répondre non ils ne sont pas
bloquées ouais ça me dérange pas
franck est d'accord je lui dit non mais
si c'est comme ça je l'enlève si c'est
pour me dire ce qu'il faut dire pendant
toute l'émission je vais l'enlever tout
de suite bon donc aujourd'hui mais
j'entende j'entends france inter
en motorisant motoriste donc à vous
demander c'est pas libre de suite le
même où tu veux chanter parce que moi je
me demandais où fans et de mètres on a
fait des récits de contes au livre
s'appelle plaisanterie c'est lamentable
ça ça s'appelle plaisanterie swiss un
recueil de poésie sur la poésie
quand j'étais jeune pour séduire les
jeunes filles sur ac river des poèmes
oui ça quand j'étais petit j'ai écrit un
truc à une belle phrase d'ailleurs vous
étiez petit c'était je la cite parce que
c'est vraiment vous allez voir tâche à
cet impôt a écrite
l'eau ne sait pas nager la preuve elle
coule ouais franchement c'est pas loin
d'être philosophe sur la vie tout à fait
c'est guy bergès ans que la petite jeune
fille commence à tomber d'achat elle
s'appelle tâche à cette tâche à 100
comme vous étiez petit effectivement où
tout le monde vous casser la gueule
mikron de rentrer et vous pouvez voir
pour résister pour résister vous avez
développé l'humour si ça il sait ça
c'est une chose que tu ne connais pas
non non non mais comme on dit si bien
qu'à la région
vous progressez beaucoup beaucoup de
glace alors donc vous avez déclaré j'en
ai marre qu'on m'invite à la télé en me
disant venez juste pour faire le con à
metz avait souvent arriver là je suis
d'accord du tout savoir de votre
spectacle déjà il sait pas fini votre
lit machin aussi le balcon du tout non
mais souvent c'est vrai que la télé
c'est c'est difficile le rang pourrait
me le dire pour confirmer ce que je dis
c'est que quand on est artiste on se
fait bouffer par la télé on sert de
faire valoir aux animateurs on est là à
côté de gens qui font des rubriques qui
présentait sleeps à faire déraper noir
aux artistes alors donnant pour acquise
à faire valoir à l'autre maintenant on
fait les vraies émissions bien je pense
c'est celle qui met en valeur les
artistes ou alors on les laisse parler
d'eux lors de ce qu'ils font et ses îles
sont pas juste là parce qu'ils sont
connus parce qu'ils font parce qu'ils
disent trois conneries et qui
déstabilise et les gens enfin dans mon
cas en tout cas on va souvent appeler
pour dire à bien faire le con machin et
lee addy jeu à la télé on est de l'achat
on a envie de la chair à audience on
sert qu'à faire de l'audience
alors on verra demain matin si vous êtes
de la chambre et si vous êtes vraiment
des achats à audience
[ __ ] ça nous apporte la célébrité la
de passer comme ça dans des talk shows à
la télévision mais finalement c'est une
sorte de pacte avec le diable
bah oui c'est ce que je viens de dire
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
enfin c'est délicat quand on fait trop
de télé qu'on a envie de faire du cinéma
on peut pas faire de cinéma quand on
nous voit trop à la télé on fait plus
rêver lège s'est voulu prudent n'aurait
pas parlé et visibles ou non
si vous deviez partir sur une île
déserte kalfine defour quel film de vous
emporteriez vous aulas va se dire j'ai
fait que des chefs-d'oeuvre alors c'est
ça c'est compliqué c'est vrai moi pas
dans vos filets raconter mes blagues
pour pouvoir rives c'est moche comme
attitude cherche à trouver
je vais vider
c'est lui qui a parlé mon cher nos repas
par lévis et montmagny avait demandé on
m'avait demandé de ne pas en parler
c'est lui qui en a parlé du cinéma des
films de 10 et moon jean-pierre de qui
des lycées c'est sympa écoutez je vais
vous dire que je n'ai pas plus vu de
film d'elie semoun étude de qui que ce
soit d'autre je suis prêt à aller au
cinéma de piste hier notre bergerac ben
oui quand même un bon moment mais la
création baisser les prix
à part ça j'aime énormément ce qui fait
bon se trouve c'est un type qui a
beaucoup de talent et puis j'avais aussi
de claude c'était pas si mal le clown
franchement charity-business non plus
c'était pas mal ça j'ai pas scarlett
e-business était un film avec smaïn mais
c'était oui c'est rigolo moi j'avais vu
à adé qu'ophélie winter
oui tout doit disparaître tout droit
d'un titre dangereuse bien ça m'a dit
toi tu te souviens quand même extrait on
vient de voir ça c'est un sketch mais
continuent quand il est seul sur scène
il a beaucoup aimé ce genre de garçon
d'achat je pense que c'est un excellent
artiste donc je respecte mes garçons qui
pour vous draguez vous faire rire
est ce que pour vous draguez réputé pour
vous draguez il faut vous faire rire ah
c'est très important
allomo à mes mots en général je pense à
l'intelligence aussi l'intelligence
aussi il a nous a montré jusque là les
deux je ne peux pas vous montrer mon
cerveau mais en tout cas j'en ai assez
que là on a compris ça l'ouverture alors
c'est spect'art revenant au spectacle
parce qu'on est là pour parler de votre
travail et pas juste pour vous regarder
faire le con dites moi vous avez déclaré
c'est dur d'écrire seul il vous manque
[Musique]
non enfin au début il m'a manqué
forcément ça ne déstabilisait de saut à
skis les biens non mais sérieusement je
sais aussi bien quand vous étiez avec
lui oui oui tout à fait oui oui non mais
c'est résumé
oui au départ il maintenant qu
évidemment c'est vrai que là cette
séparation pour moi était un peu plus
dur que pour lui j'en suis sûr mais mais
une fois que muriel robin a décidé de
s'occuper de mon spectacle mettre en
scène ce spectacle je me suis sentie
complètement en confiance et j'ai plus
pensé à lui c'est possible un jour de
vous revoir ensemble je sais pas
franchement c'est ce que vous avez dit
sur lui sa maîtresse vous avez déclaré
c'est un ex vendeur de bagnols il était
obsédé par le pognon quoi c'est pas
sympa mais c'est vrai oui
ouais c'est la vérité non ça lui fait
pas de la peine quand vous dites ça ça
lui fait pas de la paix
non je crois pas il aime ça il est c'est
vrai que c'est un homme d'affaires moi
j'en suis pas du tout hein vous avez dit
d'ailleurs oui vous avez dit j'étais un
peu lui c'était un peu le juif du
spectacle et moi le noir qui se fait
avoir
oui c'est une c'est une blague mais
c'est une blague mais c'est la vérité
c'est la vérité c'est parti c'est
ericsson et antisémite il a aussi ce nom
il a un truc formidable c'est que vous
êtes par acide est évidemment mais vous
jouez beaucoup avec le racisme vous êtes
un d un des seuls comics en france qui
joue avec le racing par exemple un jour
on vous demander si dieudonné s'en va
vous dites si dieudonné s'en va je tape
sur une poubelle pour trouver un autre
noir par exemple et comme c'est vous
personne ne dit rien ça peut paraître
méchant puisque la vue comme ça c'est
méchant non mais moi de donner je laime
je laime beaucoup encore je trouve qu'il
a beaucoup de talent mais il est parti
dans un délire qui n'est pas le mien
quoi la politique les histoires d'argent
etc
c'est pas mon truc mais que voilà c'est
tout on vous dit par exemple quand vous
avec les juifs les nazis on avec les
juifs et nazis ont pas fini le boulot
par exemple vous vous dit tout ça
c'était dans un sketch mais ça choque
personne
c'est dieudonné qu'il disait dans un
sketch était un juif et un noir qui se
taper sur la gueule mais on est très on
a souvent pratiqué je le pratique encore
le l'autodérision je me souviens qu'à
l'époque on avait une affiche ou moi
j'étais en ss bien on sait c'est
dieudonné un cucs clan puis on se
serrait la main comme ça avec un grand
sourire
donc c'est un petit peu de la
provocation quoi pourquoi vous
choisissez l'inspecteur comme spectacle
l'inspecteur oui votre lotion ce sketch
mais pourquoi c'est là dans ce sketch là
oui pourquoi
je veux vous dire en anglais en tout cas
c'est un
non j'estime que c'est un gars qui est
en garde à vue en fait ils parlent un
commissaire et il est interrogé sur ce
qu'il a fait et on s'aperçoit donc par
exemple est-ce que vous avez été arrêtés
dans votre nom mais mon spectacle en
fait c'est tout mes cauchemars
c'est la mort la police la bêtise le
racisme des cauchemars la nuit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'en referai thématiques que l'émission
karl lagerfeld car les gars on a fait
tous les cas les avec carl lang mais on
n'a pas voulu avancer trop car marche il
est mort donc voilà on fait un spécial
car l'absolument alors karl largerfeld
on faire une une hyper view vérité alors
l'hyper view c'est déjà quelque chose du
tout ces gens là vont vous poser des
questions
l'hyper yeux vérité c'est que vous
engagez bien entendu à dire la vérité
comme marie laforêt vient de le faire a
dit toute la vérité voilà alors ce qu'on
peut dire déjà pour commencer c'est que
vous avez réussi beaucoup de choses mais
surtout à imposer une image c'est à dire
vous êtes vous êtes un logotype vous
êtes une icône quoi quand on voit
qu'elle quand on voit des lunettes
noires un catogan et un éventail plus
l'éventail non parce qu'à un moment
donné il faut larguer les accessoires
awel gênant vous avez abandonné
l'éventail c'est fini oui je l'avais
pris pour une raison qu'il avait
différentes et pas pour faire une image
ouais je ne fume pas oui un débat digne
de la fumée des autres c'était seul
moyen pour s'en débarrasser d'accord
j'en fus - j'ai pas besoin d'accords
sick of allume-cigare on va vous prêter
un ventilo parce que les sig à finir
nous sommes j'aime moins que les
cigarettes bonbons tu peux y aller jean
pierre alors donc même effectivement
même si les gens savent pas toujours
très bien ce que vous faites ils savent
que vous êtes karl lagerfeld voilà c'est
une réussite comme une autre avec des
rangées de gênant qu'autre chose aux
emails un bon donc fait justement parler
car il en faut beaucoup beaucoup de
choses
alors là il ya un truc qui s'est passé
c'est que dans toutes vos sociétés dans
toutes vos activités
il ya eu une qui s'appelait qu'à elle et
qui a fait déposer son bilan khalifa x
n'apparaît pas du tout ça faisait partie
d'un groupe avec lequel s'était associé
qui est groupe vendôme et avec qui je
m'entendais pas du tout et je voulais
qu'une chose c'est la demande
débarrasser et j'ai récupéré tout mon
nom je vais récupérer votre nom voilà
c'est ce que je voulais voilà même si en
même temps tous mes autres sociétés et
puis je la verrais pas oui élan j'irai
pas vous societe vous toucher des
royalties
oui il est monsieur qu'il a géré il
vient d'être remercié par vendôme adrar
et changement de développeur c'est
génial que les chefs ayant la société
ces bandeaux donc la société cas elles
n'existent plus les
y'en a une nouvelle qui avait live
gallery que tu vois là témoigna
lagarfeld galerie des galeries à paris
qui voit là la new york et qui est nul à
monaco
voilà alors ses 48 scène donc cédé que
vous avez fait ça avec andrée putman et
commissaire qu'andrée putman
on vient d'avoir une effectivement à new
york à berlin monaco voilà c'est tout
votre monde avoue oui mais il ya
personne qui me dit vous rendez vous
faire ça ça ça c'est une chose à moi
personnellement avec mes propres sous et
ça m'amuse beaucoup plus parce que en
même temps ça peut être différent de mes
gros client c'est-à-dire chanel et fendi
vrai que je veux pas être concurrents de
mes clients oui temps je fais autre
chose alors qu'il y ait de la mode on
peut on rêver et de la mode il ya déjà
des livres des photos puisque vous êtes
on en parlera vous êtes devient formant
par les choses que je fais en italie
pour fendi rihanna l'arctique on va là
aussi puisque pour le moment il ya ce
fameux sac baguette indiqué le sac les
plus vendus du monde donc on ne vend là
aussi le sac baguette à de belles
baguette qu'est ce que c'est assez dire
ça qu'ils se mettraient près du sous le
bras et se voit quelqu'un l'a appelée
baguette un jour il est devenu le sac
baguette
voilà c'est la transpiration est le plus
porté pour le mandat mais a baissé mais
passé un nom dans tout le monde ça
l'agacé on peut passer déjà journée des
listes d'attentes
je vais voir après l'émission elle vous
l'a foot sous le bras bienvenue donc non
alors là vous êtes devenu alors ce qui
est incroyable c'est devenu un
photographe vous a vu les photos et lead
raid carl rapt dire que vous êtes
devenus ses chroniques se passer si
regardez j'ai commencé chez génère du
moment où vous avez commencé à faire des
photos 13 ans 12 ans y voit c'est ça et
vous êtes devenu photographe mais
maintenant les journaux du monde entier
vous réclame pour faire des photos de
jeu pourrait arrêter la sphère la mode
même si je voulais oui ça fonctionne
assez d'argent avec la photo pour joe
pas question faisait moi je ne travaille
plus pour gagner de l'argent car quand
vous essayez quand vous étiez petit vous
vouliez déjà être portraitiste ou carrés
qu'elle juridique des cadres et
supporter et déjà vous saviez énormément
quand vous étiez petit déjà on vous a
surnommé le kaiser de la mode mais
d'alcool pas tant j'étais plutôt l'envié
nous avait déjà cédé à ce que ce que ce
que vous vouliez faire vous étiez bien
mais je n'ai jamais changé d'idée oui
alors vous êtes allemand il faut que
j'arrive je crois que je crois tout le
monde ici peut le constater
karl lagerfeld et allemands je pense que
et ça je ne sais pas peut-être votre
bague ou la santé
alors 15 ans 46 était la leur car j'ai
quand même quelques influences
étrangères d'origine qui font que c'est
pas lui c'est elie payan vous dis que
cette année en france vous êtes un jour
expliqué pour les téléspectateurs c'est
parce qu'il avait un petit peu de retard
oui mais c'est pas grave du tout bio
tous ces contrats on mais pourquoi vous
vous êtes pas encore excusez-nous
d'abord personne puisque vous étiez en
train d'interviewer m'arrive à moi et
donc à en perdre son mandat jacques et
jean pierre dit oui c'est vrai il n'a
pas dit pardon tu sais pas quand ils
arrivent ils ont l'impression de
déranger voir alors on a juste attendu
une demi-heure en france vous êtes car
en france vous êtes l'horrible allemand
et en allemagne vous êtes celui qui est
parti donc vous dites le seul endroit
pourrait dire oui je sais bien le seul
endroit où je me sens étranger c'est mon
pays
oui c'est vrai vous aimez pas
l'allemagne c'est pas que j'aime pas
l'allemagne mais comme j'ai presque
jamais vécu en allemagne que je vis
ailleurs depuis que j'ai 14 ans c'est
assez particulier pour moi parce que au
fait je parle parfaitement allemand
je comprends que trop tout ça mais en
même temps je n'ai pas l'impression de
faire partie de ça oui comme soutien aux
enfants vous étiez vous aviez une
mentalité d'adultes à ces jeunes qui
fait les enfants quand je t envoie là et
vous vous détestez les autres enfants
que j'étais déjà assez infernal quand
vous étiez enfant parce que vous exigiez
à l'âge de 5 ans vous exigez un valet et
des boutons de manchette
oui mais c'est quand même un symbole et
un commentaire ah oui à 15 ans revenait
à bari et votre votre mère vous dit
votre père d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
vous dis ne soit jamais danseurs ou
prêtres pourquoi mais ma mère de tester
ses deux métiers pour un homme
ah oui et si le fait que je suis devenu
couturier c'est pas normal ce métier m'a
dit non c'est bien de faire ça ça prouve
que passe le prix n'en ferai pas une
horrible métier comme ça à l'époque smit
qui n'avait pas très bonne presse ces
pays on a arrangé ça le prêtre à porter
alors maintenant premiers prix dont vous
avez le premier prix d'un concours
concours international de
n avec un petit manteau chevillotte
grand chose mais ça fait toujours
sourire le manteau a été réalisée par
bellemare est devenue l'assistante
dalmat donc un succès absolument
d'assistant d'un coaching pendant les 16
17 ans c'est bien mais c'est pas le
succès le lire à l'époque c'est l'argent
qui va être à 620 couture et oui
d'accord mais à l'époque c'était plus
regardées et vie il est passé lui aussi
avant et c'est un peu pareil pour vous
vous êtes pressé directement de facteurs
à acteurs comme une lettre à la lettre à
la poste
c'était très facile - j'admire beaucoup
les gens pour qui c'est extrêmement
facile s'il a failli être à tort oui
alors votre a gagné ce concours donc
vous hills alors en lui il avait dessiné
une robe et voit un manteau si vous a
pas rendu jaloux que saint laurent soit
star 20 ans avant vous non non pas du
tout parce que moi j'avais d'autres
priorités que lui n'avait pas lutter
beaucoup plus ambitieux que moi oui donc
nos produits tout ça m'a pas gêné du
tout du tout du tout du tout j'aimerais
pas être à sa place aujourd'hui
avant pourquoi pas d'autres multiples
raisons parce que c'est mon papa de lui
donc ce n'est pas être d'accord ouais
voulait discret quand même oui c'est
bien par huissier toute façon c'est une
démission d'une discrétion totale aux
nues c'est même un truc qui fait la
réputation de l'émission bien des gens
disent bien pour on va chez ardisson
parce que moi on posera pas d'érection
personnel
totalement contre alors vous êtes vous
êtes un peu certes que souvent their
comme ça un peu grand seigneur et à
travailler beaucoup vite quand est ce
que cette notion travailler beaucoup et
quand un mec qui fait la différence
entre votre vie privée vie
professionnelle en fait il n'y en a pas
parce que je ne crois pas que ça existe
parce que si on veut faire des
séparations sa foi d'un côté à l'autre
prenez tout parce qu'on pourrait être
pas longtemps
tous se mettre d'accord est ce que pour
une fois on pourrait être tous d'accord
sacha d'achat j'aime ces moments où on
partage la même passion pour tout achat
je ne crois pas en une idée travailler
en amateur d'art wengen un coffre se
foutent vaux d'yonne je connais ce 6
août ma garde à vue à ce jour et les
gens mais tu veux lui dire toi et danse
à tout médecin pourrait si le réveiller
jean-pierre we made you know je me suis
posé de questions je devrais juste pour
ne pas risquer gros ça c'est de l'humour
ou pas c'est une attaque jean terre
parce que j'essaie de vous réveiller je
vous ai quelques fois connu brion nous
ça mais à mon avis c'est la télé qui
vous honore mais si je puis j'essaie de
vous réveiller je sais que j'aime mieux
le travail et j'écoute ce que les gars
qui dit et intéresse bientôt s'écoute
gpat raison d'intervenir j'ai écouté ben
moi j'ai de la forêt alors écoutons
cavani carlo il est d'ailleurs chez vous
chez madame messieurs vous a été payant
et nous vous en remercions
vous êtes des millions à écouter ce que
dit monsieur lagerfeld alors vous
travaillez vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous serez pour chanel on en
parlera voterez pour fan di fendi faut
le dire pour les français c'est cinq
soeurs italiennes qui ont une maison de
fourrure absolument la plus
plus grandes maisons de fous aussi du
monde et s'attache aux interprètes ont
fait l empire le monde vous avez bonne
conscience karl lagerfeld parce que vous
avez déclaré le vison est une bête très
méchante qu'il déteste l'homme comme ça
finalement
quand on fait les manteaux en suisse
vous avez l'histoire avec la fourrure
c'est bien gentil tout ce discours mais
je veux dire une chose là bas
dans ce cas là il faut pas porter une
cuillère il faut pas manger de viande ça
va loin dans oui tout ça c'est vrai et
puis après ceux de cette cause aussi
elle est très très mal défendu par deux
choses pas bardot qui des horaces et des
gens de la mode et où desjardins a plus
envie de ne pas faire de la fourrure de
la peau qu'elles soient pas contents et
puis deuxièmement aussi ces dames de
sonorisation qui prêta c'est pas parce
qu'on jette une espèce d'animal mort sur
l'assiette de mon ami en aventure les
vagues américains que nous on aurait
renoncé à faire la fourrure
parce que lesdits médiation ça fait pas
partie des choses qui m'impressionne
voilà nos donc cédé très très mauvaise
cause il ya plus de vaches queues de
vison
oui d'accord mais ça veut dire qu'ils le
sont parce qu'il faut les supprimer plus
vite les le basque n'a plus non non mais
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un chef et ses
quais aquatiques en interview sur arte
vous avez dit qu'après tout la fourrure
c'est jamais qu'une housse à viande
mais ce n est qu est ce que c d'autres à
ça donne vachement envie de porter de la
fourrure marché de la viande je veux
dire c'est pareil greg à la régie
l'avion non je compte que vous êtes
contre le port de la fourrure sur ça me
paraît évident bah non ça sert et des
régies par un caniveau pour les hommes
je n'aime pas tellement mais pour les
femmes sur sa tenue mais là vous parlez
d'esthétisme
[Rires]
c'est une hypocrisie totale alors de
quoi ça vous dérange les chaussures non
mais les chaussures
j'ai regardé les vias et du foie et
petula clark c'est du pipi d'accord mais
tu la quittes et des boutons de nacre
été arraché à à une vitre et c'est très
cruel aussi il ya un film de truffaut je
crois avec françoise dorléac et gens
d'essayer
ils sont à orly en plus d'orly et il est
pro douce et un moment donné françoise
dorléac je trouvais génial
dix agents design tu vois il ya une
femme qui porte une robe panthère
imprimé panthère et ça c'est les femmes
qui aiment l'amour ah oui c'est un
produit alors karl lagerfeld vous
dessinez un peu maintenant je vais
acheter un manteau de fourrure
ça tient à rien car la dent dure 1 parce
que vous avez dit pas inquiet mais
défendre là je partage je dis pas c'est
à dire mais ce que ce sont les vôtres
qu'à la gare c'est non mais vous vous
êtes un peu comme pierre cardin si on
veut dessiner plein de choplin d'objets
plein de trucs et comme les centres que
lui pendant douze ans de garde à vous
dites c'est devenu un marchand de soupe
il a maximois pas oui d'accord donc oui
d'accord oui par n'y aura pas n'y aura
pas à manger chez lagerfeld galerie
djamen non non non non vous dit en
parlant de chanel vous dites chanel
n'aurait pas aimé je l'aurais pas
apprécié je pense que je peux vous dire
il l'a elle n'aurait des théâtres est
alors en parlant de chloé qui est une
maison pour laquelle vous avez longtemps
dessiné chloé vient d'engager la fille
du beatles paul mccartney qui s'appelle
stella mccartney et vous avez déclaré
moi je voyais je trouve ça drôle pour
passer quand même pas très gentil bouzid
il voulait un nom ils l'ont eue mais
dans la musique on oublie que je raconte
l'histoire de cette faute
oui je suis dit ce qu'ils avaient
annoncé le journaliste qui a écrit ça et
essayer besoin de téléphone du tunnel
il n'a pas pu me joindre il a écrit ça
il me dit tu comprends c'est comme ça
que tu parles je lis me we have est
d'accord tous les dires je n'ai pas dit
mais tu parles comme ça john gadret
quant à la mauvaise réputation c'est
vraiment toi je les lui j'ai cru vous
l'aviez dit est ce que ça aurait été
prêt à le dire on vous savez on peut pas
dire qu'elles sont perdre tellement
inconnue elle est qu'il est quand même
un peu plus connue qu'elle donc oui donc
vous faire grève depuis
oui alors quand j'ai vu le film de
robert altman zappé prêt-à-porter
vous étiez il y avait quelqu'un qui
parlait de vous comprenez que c'était
vous étiez pas cité et on disait que
vous étiez un voleur me sens copieurs
pas au sens de deux volets vous avez
essayé de faire interdire le film qu'en
france on a quand même gagné dans du
coupé la séquence et dans certains pays
je suis arrivé en même qui est arrivé à
permettre un bip sur le mot voleur mais
oui mais ça a retardé la sortie après
les films dépasser d'actualité oui et on
rien qu'en france c'est sorti comme ça
quand même non je me rappelle pas si
jamais ici en allemagne j'étais arrivé
il ya des pays où il est arrivé à le
faire interdire complètement le film
c'est à dire il a été très très de
retarder le temps que le jugement soit
accepter après les compagnies si si il y
avait aucune raison mais c'est surtout
parce que c'était un mauvais film ça
aurait été un très bon film et batman a
fait très des très très beau film mais
cela était pas bon donc je viens aucun
scrupule à le faire interdire
alors hein tu as fait c'est un papa tu
l'as laissé sur le cul faut que tu
enlève ton caleçon et h missions qui
sont illégaux yak très sympathique les
seules personnes qui trouve grâce à vos
yeux karl lagerfeld c'est le cil gotha
quoi vous raffolez des particules et des
têtes couronnées non non il ya plein
d'autres gens aussi j'espère en tout cas
je m'avoue avait déclaré par exemple que
vous êtes très aimé que monaco je vais
aller le contraire dit s'appelle
rapidement après personne n'est parfait
dit marie laforêt j'étais très ami avec
les monaco vous avez déclaré je vois
certains journaux vous avez déclaré le
prince albert est très spirituel il est
oui tout à fait achat peu oui oui tout à
fait ça vous confirmez donc écoulé mais
c'est bien quand on veut passer une
soirée vraiment se marrer on appelle
albert l'a écrite lui la garde une image
très délavé d'arts et médias
mais dans le privé il est très
divertissant très amusant et fait des
imitations assez extraordinaire il
fallait il imite qu'ils ont sérieusement
ça je voudrais pas moi j'ai entendu moi
je peux vous dire qu'il est lui à
écouter faudrait je me réveille parce
que je me suis rendormi
heureusement qu'ils attachent à et
maritimes après marie laforêt parce que
jk lagarde
j'ai un petit côté ouvrard démodé ça va
pouvoir écouter on en parle encore
général du havre tasha faisait quelque
chose à dire au sujet d' albert parce
que c'est vrai qu'on vous a présenté
comme ceux des recherches ça le truc sa
future épouse on peut le dire un moment
et une couverture de paris match vous
étiez la princesse qui étaient promises
albert c'est un ami c'est un maire c'est
quelqu'un que j'estime beaucoup et
j'estime toute la famille de monaco et
enfin on vient de dire la même chose que
quelqu'un vivre c'est un garçon à
monsieur monseigneur qui était de vous
le pensez aussi qu'il est extrêmement
spirituellement spirituelle très
intelligent et vous de vous confirmer sa
vérifie ma théorie comme quoi les
français après avoir tué luis elles ont
choisi des grimaldines yangon famille de
substitution
vous êtes vous connaissez pas de monaco
vous non mais moi je suis quelqu'un de
normal donc il ya pas de problème avec
des chaussures en cuir je suis désolé
mais ça c'est pas normal
alors donc karl lagerfeld nous est ici
sinon je préfère pas monaco
karl lagarfeld vous êtes baron de bars
ou est là ne pas les titres ne vont pas
n'y a pas de particules mais bien des
titres ont su être quand même frère
c'est autre chose c'est que les
particules et croyez moi alors est ce
que n'ont ils pas ce qu'est ce que c'est
vrai car que tous les matins je peux
c'est vrai ce que tous les matins pour
égaliser la couleur et vous protéger de
la pollution fait un shampoing sec
oui c'est vrai et je l'enlève ah oui
quand-même maruschka detmers le catogan
c'est parce que vous avez jeu qui frise
la météo pour un suédois d'avoir les
cheveux qui frisera quelqu'un d'origine
suédoise
et mes origines sont mélangés en cours
de route que vous avez mis d'accord dans
cette étape les gens heureux
non merci pas compris j'ai pas compris
quand il a fait ça les fait dans tous
les sens et je les brosse qu'elle ne
soit qu'à la pollution s'est dit donc
c'est ça on a fait ça pendant des
siècles s'empressait puis découvre
beaucoup pour ça devient blanc comme ça
non métrage pour des chamois c'est déjà
poindre ici du shampoing sec et le ici
le match comme ça et je les brosse le
soir voilà il matin quand je me réveille
je me suis je suis gris foncé au lieu
des cheveux blancs c'est notamment le
blanc est assez réussi là je vous fais
pas dire c'est vrai que tous les jours
depuis ont d'ailleurs le col de votre
chien on voit bien votre chemise qui
était move comme le reste avant le col
est devenu blanc aussi voyez s'il faut
ou pas quand je crois pas car c'est vrai
que depuis l'âge de 11 ans vous mettez
des costume sombre et une cravate depuis
l'âge de 11 ans rue mais ça le fait que
vous pouvez l'enlever maintenant oui
mais finalement je me suis troupes
avaient tué pour avoir envie de les
enlever mais j'ai envie d'enlever le
cateau g sait pas ce qu'on va faire avec
mais je dis toi à questions plus
sérieuses là vous dites je n'ai aucun
but je les ai tous dépassés oui je suis
pas très ambitieux c'est fini quoi
maintenant vous non non je fais pour
faire et je pense que c'est la chose la
plus honnête et la plus agréable de
faire des choses parce qu'on a envie de
le faire voilà pour tous les pères et
mères pour arriver à faire quand vous
êtes un peu quand même
vous dites ce qui a commencé avec moi
finira avec moi par un oui ça ne me
concerne personnellement oui il me
resterait de vos six et dans la forme
que dans le fond je m'en sors pas mal
vous doutez bien je veux faire mieux
mais enfin dans le fond je écoutons jean
pierre dans le fond je m'en sors pas mal
à mon âge je pourrais être pathétique où
il est vrai est bien trop tard ok alors
philippe donc une hyper view vérité
c'est pas n'importe quel donc
l'interview je suis que le principe du
père vue donc on est déjà à 2 3 4 5
entre vous et deuxièmement comme celle
d'hyper view vérité vous allez dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
vous êtes d'accord très bien serge
khalfon lumière spéciale s'il vous plaît
tous contre moi
voilà raconte tout contre nancy c'est
tout le monde parle de vous parce que
vous avez fait un bond en avant dans les
sondages ça c'est officiel j'ai pris
quatre points au baromètre du figaro
magazine et des gens en europe il faut
les rendre ce qu'ils aiment 98 sondage
louis harris alors vous est la troisième
personnalité de droite la plus populaire
après chirac et seguin et il faut le
dire quand même l ouïe anisimov modestie
doit en souffrir
vous êtes devant madelin monsieur
madelin derrière douce vous êtes là je
ne dis ça pour vous arranger vos copains
vous êtes devant sarko buissart facile
derrière douce vous êtes devant beyrouth
ça c'est encore pire
oui berrou derrière bon alors et vous
avez dit comme je ne serai pas comme
kouchner fait plaisir d'abord d'être
devant tout ça va voir si ça parce qu'il
a dit je ne saurais pas comme kouchner
et langues
une bulle dans les sondages donc ça veut
dire que non seulement vous est la
troisième personnalité préférée de la
droite mais en plus de ça vous comptez
continuer à monter non c'est pas monter
mais quand vous faites de la télévision
quand vous avez des thèmes aussi
importants que celui des retraites moi
j'ai un bouquin aussi que j'ai encore
parlé rassurez-vous bon 90 à votre
retraite pour sauver ma retraite je le
montre à la caméra qui va nous changer
ma retraite par philippe douste-blazy
chez plon on en gagne avec le froid
s'accrocher seule balle et j'ai pris un
départ dont nommer quelqu'un nous fait
quand on fait de la politique on le fait
à la fois par ambition personnelle mais
on le fait aussi pour des idées assez
forte et j'ai eu la chance un effet
depuis une dizaine d'années que ce soit
au niveau de la santé que ce soit au
niveau de la culture d'être bon sur des
sujets qui sont en plus ni de droite ni
de gauche qui sont des sujets un peu
universelle je crois que c'est un peu
pour ça que je suis est montée comme ça
dans l'opinion et dans les sondages et
pour ça bon alors au début faut dire la
vérité vous n'aviez pas un crédit
fantastique avez votre ami seguin qui
dit êtes vous ouais douste-blazy c'est
un danseur mondain
pas sympa il y avait fillon marquant ses
deux fils et filles on sait plus
tellement qui s'est jetée aux orties
danse ça doit quelques jolies filles ont
ils dit gêné fillon connaissez fillon il
a gagné
si on disait t'as qu'à te disais il
m'est arrivé la pire chose de ma vie on
m'a pris pour douste-blazy donc tout le
monde vous brocardé un petit peu
philippe rouchon contraire cette somme
l'asie qui savent mais arrivé un truc
bien on m'a pris pour fillon
et alors ce que les gens n'ont pas noté
c'est qu'en fait vous êtes allé très
vite ses rangs 89 d'être maire de
lourdes en 93 d'autres ministres et en
98 et président du groupe udf à
l'assemblée dont qu'ils soient moins de
vous maintenant les filles ont la main
vous faites l'hyper view et cardiff
c'est quoi pourquoi vous étiez jeudi
c'est un peu le sommet d'une carrière
est souvent confiée à jos et désagréable
pour lui merci mais non il est sympa bon
je pose plus les questions que j'avais
prévu on va parler de vos clés qui est
vraiment bien
page 68 vous dit ça sans clé de lazare
bon non mais quand même c'est vrai vous
êtes vous êtes imposés par exemple à la
présidence en fin de du groupe udf
ressembler sérieusement jeudi en super
que vous êtes imposé parce que des roues
nous est en veille entre des roues et
soutenez robien et bayrou et vous c'est
vous qui avait été l'une assez parce que
tout simplement on faisait un parti
politique qui s'appelle nouvelle udf
françois bayrou devenu président du
parti est moche devenu président du
groupe se sait pas ce que je dirai tout
à fait normalement il ya une élection il
ya une campagne où j'ai battu gilles de
robien campagne électorale non mais lui
il aurait préféré
il aurait préféré pardon que ça soit ça
soit robien verrou il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de campagne électorale très dur
contre moi franchement de la france j10
franchement je le dis franchement vous
appelle à vous l'aimez great bear ou
parce que des bus vers où il était sympa
avec vous il vous a aidé comme ça tous
les deux du même coin là bas dans le
sud-ouest qui vous a aidé en attendant
caisse kilomètres l'un de l'autre
oui et un moment j'ai pris votre envol
tout seul en le laissant un peu comme ça
on vous dit on dit douste-blazy c'est un
peu le maigri de beyrouth d'abord c'est
pas les mêmes enjeux les invités l'autre
jour dans le cadre de sa campagne
européenne lourde
il a dit que nous étions des amis de 100
ans parce que mon grand-père a soigné sa
grand tante
il ajoute elle est morte jeunes ouais
vous êtes né donc en 1953 vous êtes
médecin enfin professeur fils de médecin
et dire quand michel crépeau à usson en
attaque à l'assemblée vous êtes allé lui
faire un massage cardiaque
avec kouchner et le choeur est reparti
oui les sports michel crépeau est mort
d'ailleurs parce que nous n'avions pas
de kenny d'antibes à sion au moment de
sa réanimation alors qu'ils avaient des
pompiers des médecins de l'assemblée
nationale il y avait manqué au kenya du
patient et c'est pour ça que les mots
les jours après l'hôpital cochin
on aurait pu le récupérer parce qu'elle
avait fait le coeur est reparti bon
alors dans notre adolescence vous
pratiquer le golf vous aimez la musique
classique les voitures c'est bien fou de
bagnols vous ai même fait le rallye de
monte carlo à 77
ouais et vous et il faisait longtemps
hésité entre la carrière d'andré la
médecine et la voiture en 1976 j'avais
deux solutions ou et depuis d'autres
usines
oui ou alors faire et médecine je sais
c'est bon alors qu'un jour on peut
piloter des petites voitures aussi donc
autre miracle quand vous vous lancer en
politique à lourdes pour être maire de
lourdes donc votre vous avez
effectivement quelqu'un qui est là
depuis des années qui s'appelle françois
abadie qu'un vieux radical socialiste et
vous avez un seul concurrent qui vous me
voyez venir qui s'appelle joël jarroux
rpr miracle et me fait rigoler ça me
fait rigoler je suis insensible les
choses vous avez une chose dans la vie
que je trouve insensé pour michel
crépeau pratique nommée sais rien mais
je n'ai rien gagné
vous avez l'impression de donner
l'impression que je gagne ce que vaut
une caisse veut quelqu'un meurt c'est
très désagréable
alors excusez moi de vous le dire bien
je ne me sens pas très bien vous savez
impôts joël germain trop tard pour
partir oui mais pas trop tard je
sérieusement jarrousse est vrai une
maîtrise david et puis qu'il soit décédé
début c'était un peu comme j'ai envoyé
karl zéro j'adore me clairoix je vous
laisse excusez moi est ce que je dis
plus rien là je tiens à dire ici que
j'étais pas à côté de joël j'ai roulé
sur les freins
sinon j'aurais fait un massage cardiaque
je serai toujours là vous ne seriez pas
mais sur la glace qui voulait dire dans
54% des voix dans la même question se
seraient est-ce que vous pratiquez le
vaudou expliqué lépingle
alors le 9 février 1999
y'a pas longtemps il ya eu un miracle à
lourdes le 66e miracle qu'un dénommé
jean pierre bel il y avait la sclérose
en plaques et aguerris vous y croyez
vous qu être médecin c'est aussi ça la
vraie question est ce que vous qui êtes
m ca et catholiques est ce que en tant
que médecin c'est difficile de croire
qu'il suffit d'aller à la grotte de
lourdes pour guérir la sclérose en
plaques et en tant que catholique en
même temps vous devez y croire alors
c'est les deux derniers cas parce que
l'église fait tout pour ne pas dire
qu'il ait du miracle oui c'est l'église
cash ça il faut dix ans pour être sûr
que c'est une guérison inexpliquée
ouais les deux derniers c'est une avant
dernière une jeune fille de saison
tumeurs osseuses
c'est à 2,4 près terminal avec une
métastases hépatiques donc du foie
ça veut dire à peu près deux mois deux
mois et demi maximum de durée de vie en
sicile un milieu très pauvre
le village se regroupent pour payer le
voyage à lourdes elle va à lourdes
trois mois après il n'y a plus rien ni
sur les radios ni sur le scanner ni sur
l'irm ni sur les packs histologique donc
je veux dire et la sclérose en plaques
la même chose pareille le type de type a
senti qu'il avait une chaleur en lui il
s'est levé il a marché
évidemment comme scientifique ce quelque
chose qui me sidère je n'ai pas faim il
n'y a pas d'explication à cela ce que je
vais vous dire c'est qu'il y a ce qu'on
appelle un bureau des constatations qui
tous les ans pour des milliers de
personnes constate le dossier médical et
dossier médical fait le tour du monde
ouais il y a plus de médecins qui ne
sont pas catholiques que de médecins
catholiques dans le bureau et bien il
est vrai que ces deux derniers cas sont
totalement inexpliquée on n'a jamais vu
alors à l'époque il devait y avoir
certainement des cas un peu limite
et maintenant qu'on a les scanners et
irm histologie ces cambriolages en série
de dix ans mais attendez vous avez l'air
sceptique que sceptique c'est ce que
c'est la provocation qu'on doit avoir
mon scepticisme ça veut pas dire que j'y
crois que je crois pas je prends pas
parties sont d'accord façon même si
c'est vrai 2 mais je pense qu'un jour on
voit les explications c'est très peu
quand même
le mirage à la fois mais les trucs
autour non mais ça on parle pas d'un
tournant parle pas d'eux une fois qu'on
est sûr que c'est un mur elle me demande
pas restée les bras non mais le schéma
raf est le vrai miracle de lourdes
en fait vous avez raison c'est pas c'est
l'hôtellerie ciel de vrais miracles de
wim afin de le faire m y douloureux ce
n'est pas je me dis on est bien sérieux
depuis longtemps c'est le vrai miracle
de lourdes ce n'est pas qu'il y ait des
guérisons inexpliquées c'est qu'il y ait
5 millions six cent mille personnes qui
viennent tous les autres alors que deux
cas autre miracle à lourdes phillips et
c'est un jour vous balader donc je le
rue de la grotte et vous entrez dans un
magasin qui s'appelle le magasin belge
il ya un type avec un opinel qui vous
donne un coup de couteau
bon les miracles là aussi poumon touché
vous survivez est ce que vous y voyez
sérieusement est-ce que vous y voyez
quelque chose de surnaturel ou est-ce
que non ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que j'ai eu très très peur prouvé
pendant douze ans de ma vie j'ai été
responsable des soins intensifs de
cardiologie donc j'ai reçu beaucoup
beaucoup de malades qui avaient reçu des
coups de couteau et que si la porte est
touché c'est 35 secondes devant vous
mais c'est l'artère pulmonaire ces 15
minutes quoi donc au bout de 15 minutes
16 minutes j'étais très content et très
très rassuré sur le poumon ce n'est pas
grave de la cm de taille sur le pommeau
mais bon j'étais très très bien soigné à
l'hôpital
on a aimé sauvé la vie parce qu'en même
temps il y avait
alors les couteaux à éviter la haute
voix oui est passée juste à côté de
l'oeuvre donc c'est assez désertique
quasi miraculeux et vous avez essayé du
beau tennis contre monica seles
alors est ce que vous aviez déjà pas
pris un coup de tournevis par le même
même si ces messieurs bricolage et le
type il était même si qu'il était en
sortie à l'essai est ce que ça vous a
pas rendu un petit peu plus méfiant sur
le laxisme de l'univers carcéral crise
nous a mis un coup de tournevis au juste
le temps de mettre un coup au final ça
c'est énorme problème aujourd'hui la
justice française qui ne s'intéressent
pas la dangerosité des gens mais
uniquement la responsabilité et comme
les considérer comme madame
psychiatrique
il n'est pas considéré comme responsable
a pas de son lait ne va pas en prison il
va hôpital psychiatrique
et puis à un moment donné le psychiatre
peut trouver qu'il va mieux et le laisse
ressortir
ouais et donc c'est toute la question
que le concept qui se pose aujourd'hui
l'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs mamadou
garde des sceaux pour savoir si dans les
cas de récidive pour les criminels est
ce qu'il ne faut pas non plus qui est
certes les psychiatres qui donnent leur
avis oui mais aussi quand même les
cellules et les ce type là et les effets
toujours en liberté là aujourd'hui et en
hôpital psychiatrique
ouais mais tu es qui va sortir il va
venir vous voir la l'entarteur version à
versions dites moi vous savez qu'il est
albanais quand même avec tout le mal que
vous donnez pour les ailes s'est pas tu
pourrais vous même vous êtes sa balle
échappait lazitch ahmed adnan cif qui
évite albanel mais c'est quand même
incroyable
je voudrais pas que même donné trop de
messages négatifs sur lui mais nombre de
tentes et toi d'abord parce que nombre
d'abord parce que très sérieusement je
ne lui en veux pas dans la mesure où les
malades
c'était un match 6 4 x 2 contre quand on
dit qu'il est malade c'est ça qu'il fait
bon et quand même payé par jack lang il
faut que vous avez fait ce qu'a fait le
pape le pape jean paul ii il est allé
voir alliés axa dans sa prison quoi oui
bien sûr quand di la fé aussi au moment
des faits parce qu'ils avaient intérêt à
le faire c'était quel intérêt il avait
pas ce que parce que c'est le papy les
représentants de tous les catholiques
qui se doit d'avoir un geste de
miséricorde du pape même que nous
continuons à regarder car 0 est ce que
vous l'avez vous l'avez rencontrée je
suis rencontré deux fois cette occasion
la surface il aime bien l'humour aussi
longuement hésité en fait chaque fois on
lui pose la question est ce que vous
connaissez de ste blazy répond ne jouait
pas cet homme
j'ai pas du tout qui sait il était rare
et donc
je me suis souvent posé la question et
je crois que je vais le faire ouais je
pense que j'irai le voir très bien alors
quand vous étiez ministre de la santé
vous êtes battus contre le sida
logique 1 quand vous étiez ministre de
la culture s'est battu contre le front
national
logique mais vous savez bien que je vous
poserai la question il ya que jack lang
que vous n'êtes pas arriver éliminé
parce que le sida se soigne que le front
national est en train de se casser la
gueule pouvez pas comparer l étroit mais
ceci étant je vous réponds langues
jack lang a eu une chance à générer et
du talent mais une chance c'est qu'il
reste ministre de la culture disant oui
comme andré malraux et je reconnais
qu'en dix ans on peut quand même marqué
au cynisme
[Musique]